[Musique]
c'est une mission scientifique qui a
tout d'une expédition
un groupe de chercheurs français et
sénégalais savons sa moto dans la
brousse
sur des pistes à peine tracé
[Musique]
un peu trop chargée donc on peut pas
aller très très vite
en tête derrière leur chauffeur
christophe l'aventurier et pattern
doctoraux en botanique ils se rendent à
l'extrême est du sénégal à la recherche
de nouvelles plantes qui n'auraient
encore jamais été découverte
particulièrement de nouvelles espèces de
fougères c'est fougères qui pousse
apparemment dans l'eau est relativement
en altitude sont a priori
pour certaines inconnues encore au
sénégal
pour espérer les trouver il faut
dépasser les derniers villages et
s'enfoncer toujours plus loin
à temps
le but du voyage
le bois 6
une cascade
particulièrement préservé
et qui n'apparaît sur aucune carte
[Musique]
elle est super d'un terrain
dont les sites les plus cacher la nature
regorge encore de secret chaque année
2000 nouvelles espèces de plantes sont
découvertes dans le monde
les falaises sont des millions d'accès
difficile donc très peu perturbé et donc
on a énormément de chance de trouver des
fêtes très peu connue au sénégal et
peut-être ne faut pas pas une nouvelle
cour nation et ses nouvelles espèces
c'est au coeur de la cascade qu'ils
espèrent les trouver
c'est à christophe et théo que revient
la tâche périlleuse c'est aux 70 m de
descente en appel a toujours peur de ce
qu'elle fait la gueule et après ben
un peu d'excitation
ça fait une bonne adrénaline
sa bouche trou tu me dis je remonte au
dessus
juste accroché à cet arbre christophe se
lance dans le vide
au cours de sa descente il va donc
collecter des spécimens
c'est l'objectif même de la botanique
l'étude des végétaux au plus près
alors j'essaie évidemment de par prendre
trois fois la même
c'est donc tout ce que je trouve nouveau
bas je le prends c'est assez simple je
travaille simple un peu physique quand
même un peu dangereux mais
rafraîchissant
avec des trombes d'eau sur le casque il
est difficile de discerner chaque plante
alors les deux chercheurs cueille tout
ce qu'il voit sous le contrôle de leurs
collègues restés en bas
les sacs se remplissent
et c'est le plongeon final
juste en bas de la cascade pattern à lui
déjà une première surprise
[Musique]
pour sa part
c'est le rêve de tout botaniste être le
premier a recensé une espèce pour
augmenter les connaissances des
écosystèmes de la planète et donc mieux
les protéger
toutes les plantes collectés vont partir
au laboratoire pour vérification
en attendant pattern les dépose avec
soin dans son herbier
et plusieurs sont très précieux pour les
ranger avec délicatesse il ya beaucoup
de travail à tête et voilà vivement que
d'autres missions et dans d'autres
endroits
au 21ème siècle la botanique a encore de
quoi nous étonner
selon les estimations 10 à 20% de la
flore mondiale serait encore à découvrir